when men women cheat it's just because
they're horny i think you can have sex
with another girl and love your woman
you say jonathan because you won't love
that people you don't love that girl
that you're beaten did it you all love
her but
the the love making that you do to your
woman is different to
the beating that you do to any other
girl so you're saying it's considered
cheating when emotions get involved yeah
yeah
and that's and that's and that's and
that's where a woman comes into it
because women before they can even sleep
with a man they have to build that sort
of emotion in their head before they can
even sleep with a man
jonathan so so i believe men don't cheat
i think i think women cheat
wait so just to go for your like your
answer if you're saying and i i'm not
saying you because it's
a common thing that like oh guys are
cheating because they want someone to
have sex with if you're like why don't
you just tell your partner like you know
like i agree with that i think i think
yeah i think yeah i think what's it i
think with that no way i think many men
i think men should actually be honest
and tell their partners
and be like yo this is how i am in it
like but it was it
it goes to it
was saying earlier it depends on the
status of the man john decides it
depends on the matter it depends on the
status of the man because some men don't
have the i was telling this my friend
the other day someone can't afford to
tell kills that thank you they can't
afford it that they literally can't
afford to lose you lose everyone lose
everything because but a certain man can
afford to tell you that and you have to
tell you what you know
you told you that i told you that oh yo
i i might step out i might step out no
but i'm not even saying that i might
step out i'm saying why don't you come
to your wait what no you hey let a
finish please can i can i say my piece
my question is i'm not saying oh hey
babe i'm gonna step out i'm saying why
don't you come to your woman if the if
you're saying that you need more sex why
aren't you coming to your woman hey like
i i need to [ __ ] some more like
i can't lie to you one girl can't
satisfy my mother thank you bro you
don't act like it's yeah
so
that's fine if you say that and like
specifically if you're coming to a
relationship saying that like hey like i
have to be polygamous i'm not gonna lie
to you like
i'm going to be sleeping with other
people or whatever and that's why again
i i stated when you're beginning this
relationship you're you're both agreeing
i love you you know but you're very
competitive no i'll tell you why i tell
you why in the sense of this you know
what a man's like right
i do know what men are like but thank
you i know a lot i know a lot of people
that will be just fine
you're trying to find a needle in the
haystack you're trying to find a needle
no listen because i'm asking a genuine
question so the thing is why why i asked
because if you if if this statement is i
need to have more sex why are you not
coming to your it's not more sex that i
want sex yeah it's different so if it's
if it's explain the difference like
please do like okay so okay all right
can i say something not every okay when
i'm having intercourse with a a female
not no sex is the same okay as a man we
our sexual urges get
fulfilled when we go for variety or we
go for i want a big battery this time i
want a small but it's not necessarily
that i i'm
her connected to that is what i i'm i
want the whole no
i want to really
bust in it and i want to get to where
i'm i'm at sometimes i would even i
would even
um i would even be where i needed to be
and be and been like why did i even go
there yeah like why did i even bother
with her like you know i'm just gonna
say i know i'm gonna get into headache
now
with her over this thing just because i
went like you know what i'm saying we
had a physical act and now it's very
emotional now and it's like i didn't
even want it to go emotional where i
wanted you to stay there on my level but
you're never going to be on my level
because you're not you know so
so i'll give you a second
so to go back what you said earlier
about understanding
men and women and how they think and how
they talk you you mentioned learning
spanish learning the language i would
say is different than understanding a
person and how they operate if you
already know that engaging sexually with
a woman is going to be emotional for the
woman
why why stick to why don't you
perfect why don't you just stay with the
one person but even if you want to step
out and sell your while go ahead do that
why be in a relationship with a a woman
and put her through that because you
know it's emotional i'll tell you why
you think it's i'm being in a
relationship with a woman but again who
controls a relationship a man controls
relationship so if like you are out
there looking for a relationship
correct
just like many a lot of girls are
looking for a relationship a man might
say you know what you're looking for a
i might use that to my advantage like
okay i see you desperate i'm going to
use that i'm not really looking for a
relationship but if you want to hear the
right words you're going to hear the
right words right
you know what i'm like as a man you know
what my intentions are i want to get to
that nookie so you if you know what my
intentions are you have to
i'm just being serious
you need to put in like what you want
from that relationship like some girls
are like listen i'm not giving it up
unless this guy takes me gauchos or
makes me like this i'm not giving it up
like oh he has to marry me before you
give this to me or it depends on what
you put your price on in it what your
the price of your
couch is that's what i'm right that's
what i'm saying if you're obviously if
you're not in a relationship do whatever
you want but if you establish that
relationship with that woman and you
step out you established it no because
you both talked about that
you both talked about you both
established it it was a common
conversation you said you my woman i'm
your man this that in the third
but you still stepped out
why if you both are on the same page
about love i love you i love you my love
i love i love listen if a man tries it i
would i'll die speaking to the mic i
will i will kill for you i would work
till my back breaks for you i would
give you the best kids
but i'm saying to you when that espanol
passes and she's looking
like a river
i don't mean to do what i'm gonna do but
off
and you know what bro don't don't hate
me
i love you bro i just said i loved you i
love you bro like i don't like her like
i'm saying like
you're not you're not bending at your
back like how she bends her back bro
she's not
you're not dirty like how she's dirty
but i don't want a dirty girl i don't
want a dirty girl
i believe a man's nature is to want to
pursue anything he can however that only
depends if he can do that which would
depend on his status wealth or
essentially clout if he if he's able to
do that then he will do that a woman is
trying to attract the highest valuable
man she can
so at that moment you've got to
understand can every woman do that no
can every man go and pipe as many girls
as they want no no so you need to take
into consideration that although this is
what you want
you may not be able to do that
so should it be a conversation up front
yes like
like
like you said lie to us you sit down
with us at your significant other and be
like let's look at each other lie to us
let's look at each other i can get any
man i want and you can get any woman you
want is it this should not be a
conversation when you sit down they're
not going to say for the woman to get
any man she wants but this is what i
will say
so you're you're saying that you want
your woman to go for any guy oh no yes
no no no no no no no
no because what i'm saying and you're
going to 100 agree with what i'm saying
along the lines of polygamy
you are wanting the guy to be the one
reaching out to multiple women you don't
want the woman reaching out yes that's
fine i i'm not i'm saying you're gonna
agree with this
but the point is like it's not it's not
for the woman to step out like you're
and
a lot of a lot of women will agree to
that a lot of women will like that's why
i'm saying if you start the relationship
and say hey this is the the foundation
of our relationship a lot of people will
go for that which is why i all i keep
saying you start off and say this is how
our relationship is because if you say
it from the beginning
there's people that are going for that i
i love how you said that honesty right
honestly right so why are girls not more
honest
you go you go you go you go on dates you
go on dates that you're not interested
in the men in there you do things that
men are not interested in and we're
getting away
for honesty we want honesty we want
honesty honesty is what we want
okay women don't trap men go on honestly
that's what we want darling did you not
say that men are responsible for the
relationship so you're choosing to stay
in that if you're the one responsible
for the relationship
you're choosing to be intertwined in
that no but the thing is yet if a girl
if a girl is stepping out
that that doesn't mean you're we're not
in a relationship then
we're not in a relationship so for me
still yeah obviously because you know
what we're like before of course i don't
mean
oh
[Laughter]
i don't even know where to start like
what what my brothers are saying yeah
that's
what my brothers are saying yeah
i love all of you yeah but
you lost smoking skittles
because i i can't i can't sit here and
and kind of like accept and agree with
what you're saying i i mentor
young boys yeah they're gonna hear what
you guys are saying yeah and be like wow
like okay i guess this this is where it
is
you said something along the lines of
first let me just say this here
a man that cannot control his sexual
desires cannot control his life okay
so
do you mean false that's false
okay if you want me to elaborate on that
point i will
the point i was going to make is yeah
you know
how you are okay like if we go with
nature okay a man is the way he is if
you know that this is the way this is
the way you are yeah
and you choose to accept it
you are at fault
how can i can i say this because it's
not everything like i was born
everyone has like characteristics that
they're born with yeah
but not every characteristic is a good
characteristic definitely not every
habit is a good habit if you know that
with you you have a bad habit it's your
it's your responsibility to change that
breath i cannot i cannot sit here and
accept that okay well i'm a man i guess
hmm that means that
sexually i want to explore i want to do
this but i know that i'm with someone
and me doing this is going to hurt that
person but i don't care because that's
the way i am i'm going to do it that
does not make sense to me
you know the way you are you know and
you know the way a woman is bro yeah
you
you because i know listen i know what
i'm saying it's a bit well to something
he's been here for thousands of years
bro does not mean you have to accept it
does not mean that you have to go go
with it
you know what i mean yeah but he's been
here his premise is the front here for
it's been here for time and i'm saying
polygamy has been there for time
racism has been enough for time do we
have to sit here and say that okay this
is the way is this is the way it's
always been so that's what we're going
to do change it okay change your
behavior
if you know exactly that's what i'm
coming to the state of mind yeah you
know that okay this is what i this is
this is the way i am this is what i'm
gonna do and i refuse to accept it i
can't sit here i can't i can't go to my
girl and be like oh babes yeah you know
i'm a man you know you know i'm a man
huh
was the original question just again
it was if cheating is different from men
and women guys and girls isn't it
is it not it is don't even care it is
different
but no but this is my point it is
different but your channel yeah no no no
no no let me let me finish let me finish
let me finish let me finish or we
establish why it's different because
women are more emotional yeah they're
men this thing over my point is yeah as
men we do not have to accept that it has
to be this way
so how would you want to be aware
however how would you want it to be that
men also be emotional to it as well
i think you can discipline yourself to
the point where you don't have to sleep
with everything that moves
okay okay well firstly
random sleep with bare girls that move
but not every single girl first and
foremost secondly yeah that's got
standards yeah
secondly
to bring it back in here i hear you
saying oh you gotta change it this this
that but this idea of of um what's it
called guys being with one woman
came along
was there before monogamy came about
whether you know or not people naturally
yeah from the start guys have been going
around with different girls monogamy
came in for society and for what's
called economic benefits like
capitalistic yeah capitalism like you
marry into somebody you get uh you get a
a
a girl who's of a lower status and then
she gets married into a guy um who's of
higher status due to the fact that it's
going to benefit somebody so all the
other way around yeah what is or is for
the point of it benefiting
the the original party so back in the
days medieval times the original party
being men
or women or women i'm not going to say
i'm not going to call it
however however
the queen's husband is not called king
but let's go medieval times yeah you
will get people from other villages or
other lands marrying into the uh
marrying into a king yeah even though
they didn't like him or whatever
whatever just for the sake of their
alliances can be built
that's the whole point of minigaming
i must say that's one of the points of
why
monogamy came about but you need to
understand polygamy is it's so natural
whether you believe or not i'm not
saying it's good about the effects that
has cool it can it can do a lot i don't
i don't agree with the effects i ain't
different however you also need to
understand polygamy is one of the most
natural things that there is about
countries other things
if men can do it and all other men can
i could have i could marry free women
yeah and women womankind would be like
oh you such a
but i could be single and say i sleep
with 100 women they'll be like okay you
want to do what you want to do bro i
have dedicated my life to free women
right i've said whatever i own will be
split three ways equally for you three
women no he's saying hypothetically
i don't think it's wrong that's why you
need to say whatever is good for your
partner but as long as you're providing
for that family no but what my point to
you when you said that was is that girls
sometimes don't know brother lie to them
bro if you're if if she knows if you
know that she's not taking you this is
before we carry on before we carry on
we've got a special guest in the
building sara yes
[Applause]